وقع محمد صلاح في حب
كرة القدم لأول مرة عندما كان يبلغ من العمر سبع سنوات في قرية صغيرة
في شمال مصر في الرابعة عشرة من عمره
وقع على أول نادي محترف
له المقاولون العرب في القاهرة ،
وكان النادي بعيدًا عن المنزل
وسيستغرق الأمر ثلاثة.  أربع حافلات أو خمس حافلات
للذهاب إلى التدريب ، هل تخيلت يومًا
ما عندما كنت طفلاً في مصر ، كنت ستلعب
هنا أنا ممتلئة لا أستطيع أن أقول عندما كنت في
السابعة من عمري ، لا سألعب
هناك عندما أبدأ  للعب في
الفريق الأول ، قلت حسنًا الآن يجب أن
ألعب مع الفريق الأول في مصر وأبدأ في
تحسين نفسي أكثر ولم ألعب
مع الفريق الأفضل في آسيا ، لكني
ذهبت إلى اللغز منذ ذلك الوقت
قلت نعم "  ذاهب للعب مع النادي الأعلى ،
لذا فقد تقدمت خطوة خطوة خطوة بخطوة ،
فقد تقدم محمد في توقيع بازل في
2012 ، مما ساعدهم في الوصول إلى الدور نصف النهائي
من الدوري الأوروبي في ذلك العام
، وسرعان ما تم ملاحظة سالا ، وسرعان ما جاءت لندن تدعو في عام
2014.  وقع لنادي تشيلسي ايطاليا كانت
وجهته التالية التي لعبها خوفا
وتينا  لبضعة أشهر قبل
الانتقال إلى الجنوب للتجول في شحذ مهاراته
في مسيرة Eternal City Salle التي
ضربت الستراتوسفير في يونيو 2017 عندما
وقع في ليفربول ، هذا هو أول
نادي لك في الدوري الممتاز بالطبع أنت في
تشيلسي أيضًا ثم تخرج.  قرض
لتلائم تينا وتذكر ما حدث
في تشيلسي ، هل تشعر بخيبة أمل لأنه
لم ينجح في ذلك ، لذا أشعر أنه
لم يكن لدي فرصتي هنا ، لذا يجب أن
أغادر ، يجب أن أترك الأمر في ذهني
لا أفعل  أريد أن أكون مثل شخص يجلس
على مقاعد البدلاء وينتظر أن يكون مثل رقم
أربعة أو خمسة أو أن ألعب دقيقتين
وهو لا يزال في النادي الكبير لا يعمل
، ذهبت إلى فالنتينو ثم بعد ذهابي إلى
روما
كان علي أن أقوم بالموسم  كلاهما
أصفر ، لقد أبليت بلاءً حسنًا هناك وعندما
أتيحت لي الفرصة للعودة ، أقول نعم
حان الوقت للعودة إلى إنجلترا